it's pretty shocking I mean the cost of
living crisis is impacting families
across the country of course but for the
military they have a special offer they
get subsidized accommodation subsidized
food fuel grants to make the military an
attractive place to work and also to
compensate for the inconveniences of
military life so the fact that some
military personnel are still in crisis
should be pretty shocking I've seen a
report by the chaplaincy the RAF
chaplaincy on morale across the whole
force and it has a quote in there an
anonymous quote saying that food bank
the food bank is popular it says that
food bank use is um being seen in a
number of units the majority of units
across the country it says it is still
single digits of families per unit but
still shocking that that's happening and
at Raf coningsby a food bank was set up
there it's a big base in Lincolnshire
where our typhoon debt squadrons are
based I've been told that it was set up
by an aviator to get donations from
service Personnel to give to civilians
in the local community but that actually
A source told me that RAF Personnel have
been using it too and we've spoken to
Sarah Atherton MP who had some words on
this crisis
I am hearing stories from Charities
about service Personnel uh seeking
hardship grants and also going to food
banks now I know the mod have tried to
address this in some way so they've cut
their accommodation increased charges by
one percent
um food charges have been frozen and
they're going to introduce wrap around
Child Care from the next academic year
um but it's not good to hear these
stories uh particularly from our service
personnel
to the documents that we've seen relate
to RAF the situation inside the RAF I've
been told from sources in the Royal Navy
and the army that there's similar
hardships there and RAF spokesperson
um made reinforce the point that this
food bank at coningsby is for the local
community and wasn't set up for
personnel and they reiterated the
different types of help that is
available for personnel and the fact
that there is support for child care
everybody's waiting for the pay review
settlement which has been delayed it
should have come out before the
beginning of April it should come soon
whether or not there's going to be a a
big enough increase in pay to offset the
suffering at the moment remains to be
seen but no one's very hopeful okay for
now Deborah thanks very much